pendant le jeu ne trouve pas mes mots
jamais nous n'aurions imaginé remporter
ce prix nous sommes tellement heureux
tellement heureux ici medan et banda
jeune danny unique au tuning ok mais je
crois qu'il a un moment particulièrement
opportun de l'histoire et ça se produit
aujourd'hui nous l'attendions après des
millions d'idées je le tenais gens me
voient comme fallait du matin
elle souhaite faire part de toute ma
reconnaissance et tout mon respect pour
les membres de l'académie qui ont pris
cette décision merci du fond du coeur
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir tout le monde est là je souhaite
remercier notre réalisateur est coupable
mais notre réalisateur monsieur ben
merci d'être celui que tu es moi j'aime
tout chez lui j'aime son sourire j'aime
ses cheveux un petit peu faim j'aime sa
manière de s'exprimer sa manière de
marché particulièrement j'aime sa
manière de réaliser que j'adore chez lui
c'est son sens de l'humour quimby mais
aussi le fait d'auto dérision il ne se
prend jamais au sérieux
merci maman merci du fond du coeur
highlight ou feignent des tuniques je
souhaite remercier tous ceux qui ont
soutenu le film parasites qui ont
travaillé ce film qui ont aimé ce film
vraiment souhaite adresser mes
remerciements à mon frère qui a toujours
soutenu notre rêve qui nous a permis de
le construire
même lorsque ça semblait inatteignable
est impossible merci du fond du coeur à
mon frère jeff et puis oui one teach
souhaite adresser à des remerciements
tout particulier à notre public coréen
vraiment nous a soutenus du fond du
coeur qui nous a suivis sur l'ensemble
de nos films un public qui jamais une
haïtienne et de nous donner des avis
ronen ces francs quant à ce qu'ils
estimaient dans as tes pensées de notre
film de nos films et je crois que il ne
faut jamais se reposer sur nos lauriers
il faut continuer à travailler en tant
que réalisateur en tant que producteur
il faut continuer de travailler et sans
vous réalisant notre public coréen ne
serions pas ici ce soir merci du fond du
coeur
[Applaudissements]